ALAN SEALES: This show is
very unique, and partially
why I enjoy it so much is
because I feel like this
is more musicians on stage
versus actors more or less.
I mean, do you guys find
a distinction in that?
ANDY TAYLOR: Somebody else talk.
JOANNA CHRISTIE: It does
feel like playing in a band,
for a lot of the show.
But we're all pretty
much primarily actors,
I think, really, that just
play instruments as well.
So I don't know.
There's no distinction.
It's all blurred.
We're doing what
the show requires,
which is acting and
playing and singing.
ARTHUR DARVILL: On my tax
return, I put actor/musician.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JOANNA CHRISTIE: If that helps.
ANDY TAYLOR: I have to say, I've
done a show-- if you're like,
oh, it's so amazing.
There are shows where the
actors play instruments.
I was in one that
won all the words.
And it was Sam Mendes
who did "American Beauty"
and it was his "Cabaret."
And they're reviving
it actually recently.
But that was much more like
a couple of hot Kit Kat girls
who quit playing
violin in fifth grade.
And then they were
in the band later on.
Whereas these guys
could all-- sure,
we could all actually
play our instruments
pretty much before
we got the gig.
We've learned to play other
things more, but we're actors,
but all of us have had
that 10-year immersion
thing where we got
good at something.
ALAN SEALES: So do you enjoy
playing your own instruments
on stage more than
playing with a band.
ARTHUR DARVILL: Yeah.
I've never been in a band
that's this big before.
I've always had a dream
of having a massive band.
And suddenly, I've got it.
It's great.
And it keeps it fresh and alive.
It's slightly
different every night,
because someone's in a bad mood
or someone breaks a string.
ALAN SEALES: Well,
what happens, then,
if you guys break a string?
Do you just say stop the
show, I gotta' restring.
PAUL WITTY: Well, we do theater.
We do theater.
We're used to it.
Stuff goes wrong every night.
The audience never realizes
it, but stuff is always
going wrong.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PAUL WITTY: And like all the
little things that go wrong,
we hear it, and
we see it, and we
know kind of what's happening.
But it's all about
improv-ing in that moment
and staying with it.
BROWN SHIRT BACK: And there's
contingency plans for that.
Like, if Arthur breaks a string
during the very first song,
there's somebody
else that's assigned
to pick up that song, to pick
up the guitar on that song.
I mean, there's a
whole list of who
takes what when a string breaks.
So for the sake
of the sound guys
not going "who the
hell's playing?
Oh God," we have an
actual contingency plan.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
How many of you guys
are original cast?
Are any of you?
BROWN SHIRT BACK: Yes.
ALAN SEALES: So you
recorded the soundtrack not
in isolation booths, right?
PAUL WITTY: Yeah, well, we
did it with Steve Epstein,
was the producer of the album.
And he had just done an album
with Yo-Yo Ma and Chris Seeley.
He did the goat rodeo sessions.
And the way they
recorded that album,
it was like they did
it in like a farmhouse.
And they all sat
in the same room
and played together, rather than
each being in isolation booth,
listening with headphones.
So Martin, our music
director and Steve Epstein,
kind of got together
and they decided
that that's kind of what
they wanted to do with this.
And make sure that it
felt like we were all
playing together, rather
than playing to a track.
And so hopefully, what
came off was a very kind
of raw session
sounding-like thing.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, that was
another question I guess I had.
I was thinking about it.
The music is so raw.
And I think it's written and
designed to sound like that
and to come together
in that sort of thing.
But it's well rehearsed and the
pre-show music, the pre-show
that you guys do,
you have set songs.
Do you do the same songs
in the pre-show every time?
ANDY TAYLOR: Yeah, anybody else?
ADAM WESLEY BROWN: Well,
we have a rotating list
of about 20 or 30 Irish
and Czech folk songs.
And part of the cool thing
about, like Arthur was saying,
about being in a band is
that you come in every night,
and right where you
sign in, they normally
have a list of the songs
that are going up that night.
So it's like you
come in and find out
what the set list
is before you go out
and get on with the band.
DAVID PATRICK KELLEY:
And when we started,
we were asked to bring in songs.
And so we contributed a lot
of them, the things we had.
And you know, the thing
that's great about
is it gives-- you know,
there've been other shows where
musicians have played, but
it gives you ownership.
You really feel like
you're participating.
I know you here at
Google know a lot
about the strategy
of making people
feel like they're participating.
And that really helps us.
We own the songs.
We help express the other
characters' emotions as well as
our own when we
step on to do it.
But the songs, in particular,
in the beginning are meaningful.
If you've brought them in,
and just by happenstance
they wanted things that
weren't such Irish cliches,
and it comes from John Tiffany,
our director, and from Glen
Hansard, of course,
the pub culture, where
people would get in the pub
and if you couldn't express
your emotions through
words, you could sing it.
And so that's the idea of that.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, and we have
microphones in the aisles
if you guys want to ask
questions from the audience.
ARTHUR DARVILL: We'll sing.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Or sing.
ANDY TAYLOR: (MOCK
DEEP VOICE) Well,
the problem with that is--
ALAN SEALES: The choreography,
as well, in the show
is very, very unique.
And I haven't seen
anything like it.
And I quite enjoyed
the choreography,
How did that come about?
It was a lot of improv
to start, right?
ANDY TAYLOR: Yes, Steven
Hoggett is our movement
director/choreographer.
And why are you guys laughing?
Zygo, why don't you
answer it, Zygo?
J. MICHAEL ZYGO:
Sure, in the process
of creating the show--
I'm one of them all.
I feel like I'm hiding
behind everybody-- people
were asked to
contribute movements.
And all of the movement
is based on the emotion.
It's very rooted in the
motion of everything.
And there's nothing like, you'll
see in "Newsies," where there's
pas de bourree, turn,
turn, turn, kick, you know.
ANDY TAYLOR: We're
not "Newsies."
J. MICHAEL ZYGO:
We're not "Newsies."
ANDY TAYLOR: Cause no one could.
We would put it in
if we could do it.
J. MICHAEL ZYGO:
But yeah, it's all
meant to enhance and kind
of embellish upon the music.
And so everything
is really cohesive
and works together,
so that you never
notice one thing
more than the other.
And everything is just kind of
an accent to everything else.
ANDY TAYLOR: Right.
If I may, Hoggett
broke us up in Boston
when we did this
workshop and not really
knowing what was going
to happen with the show.
Hoggett broke us up into
groups and said, you're bored,
you're sitting at a table.
And we can just come up with a
story of a couple of gestures
that you could
teach one another.
And so we would all do
it in our little groups.
And those little pods of actors
came back and taught movement
to everybody else.
And I'd say 60% or
70% of certain songs
are all extrapolated from
movement that people came in
within that little session.
And they were
like, you're bored.
It wasn't specific, but
then in the bank scene,
when they're trying to
get money from this sort
of jaded old
banker, they awaken.
Their little gestures that
they make that are very small,
but they're very, very
powerful in capturing
the emotional essence of
the scene or the music
in a very simple gesture,
like a classic iconic move
or something.
And it's all from the actors.
ALAN SEALES: Is it all set now?
ANDY TAYLOR: It's all set now.
But it was found
material from the actors.
Steven Hoggett's has
got a company in the UK
called Frantic Assembly.
And I don't know, like
15 years or something.
And it's really established and
really well known in the UK.
And it's totally like
his signature, his style.
If you see all their work
is really similar to this.
It's all like what
Zygo was saying
about from an emotional place.
It's not just move
your arm here and then
it's all right, gut rolling.
It's amazing to watch.
J. MICHAEL ZYGO: And then
one of the other challenges
was creating choreography
that people could do well
playing instruments,
like the end of Act One.
That song we just played "Gold."
Every one of us who was playing
that song and singing it
is also dancing.
And I remember the first day
I got into rehearsal down
at the New York
Theater Workshop,
I was the only new guy there.
And they'd all already
established most of it.
And the first thing we
did on the first day
was started to learn the
choreography for "Gold."
And I was already intimidated,
but then I looked over
across the room,
and this guy's got
a cello strapped to his chest.
And I'm like is that guy
dancing with a cello?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
J. MICHAEL ZYGO: What
the hell is this?
ANDY TAYLOR: Not well.
I didn't have to do either
play, sing or dance particularly
well, obviously.
ALAN SEALES: You
have a cello harness.
ANDY TAYLOR: Yeah, we
kind of invented it.
PAUL WITTY: I want to
tell the story about when
we were learning "Gold"
in Cambridge and all
in fear of losing our jobs
because we couldn't dance
and play instruments
at the same time,
and Andy was
particularly freaking out
because he was
like, well, I don't
want to get cut
out of this number.
He's like I got
a fricking cello.
It's like what am I going to do.
So he had a belt on, took
his belt off, wrapped it
around his neck and he
tied it to the cello.
And I was like that is baller.
It was so good.
And I was like, all right,
if he can figure out
a way to dance with
his cello, I think
I can figure out a way
to do it with my guitar.
And it was inspiring
to see everyone
sort of rising to the occasion.
It was a lot of new demands and
we fueled each other that way.
You'd see someone sort of
rising to it, and like OK.
Yeah, I should do that too.
ARTHUR DARVILL: It's
great the moment
that you-- I'm looking
out towards the audience.
You guys are all dancing.
But as soon as
you start dancing,
I see people just going, oh my
god, look [WHISPERING] doing.
(AMERICAN ACCENT)
Oh, that's amazing.
ALAN SEALES: You're
saying, the choreography
represents emotion,
and it represents
the meaning behind
the songs, right?
So I mean every night,
like show after show,
you do eight shows a week.
I mean, it's got to be
very emotionally taxing.
Because this is about
anonymous guy and girl,
but the whole
ensemble-- you guys
are all very involved
and onstage constantly.
ANDY TAYLOR: I think that's
an underrated tas-- I mean,
it is trickier than it looks
to just night after night,
just be sort of detached,
be an audience member.
ADAM WESLEY BROWN: I will
say that I think all of us
are big fans of not only
the story that is told,
but the movie that was a hit,
that won the awards, and also
Glen and Marketa's music.
I know for a fact that
myself, when I first
saw the movie years and years
ago, it struck me in such a way
that I said if there's ever a
show or something like that,
I got to be a part of it.
But I think it
fuels us each night,
like we were talking about
with the pre-shows set list,
But as well with this
company of people,
I mean, we all love
what we do so much
and have so much damn fun doing
it that it really never-- I
mean, sure, It gets
tiring because you
do it eight show a week.
And we hang out with
each other all the time.
And we get on each
other's nerves.
And it's like a family though.
And it's really
lovely to go out.
I think we're very
blessed in that we
get to go out every
night and tell the story
and sing these songs.
And people are so
moved afterwards,
that it kind of keep us going.
I don't think there's
ever a time we go, oh, I
don't want to go
into work today.
ANDY TAYLOR: Except
today, apparently.
I mean, most of
the time, I agree
we usually are really
eager to get to work.
ADAM WESLEY BROWN: Laugh it
up, laugh it up, fuzzball.
Laugh it up.
ANDY TAYLOR: Sorry, he missed
out on the tour of lunch.
So he missed out.
ARTHUR DARVILL: I was
going to say the guys who
started the original
cost of this,
you've done over 600 shows.
And it's like I've never
done that many shows a day.
I've never done anything
that many times at all.
DAVID PATRICK KELLY: Yeah,
it's a blessing, you know.
As an actor, for 43 years you
can't-- when you're in a hit.
It's so rare.
And the thing about this
show is that so many things
came together, like an
aligning of the stars.
As Joanna said,
Steven Hoggett had
this company Frantic Assembly.
They did the same kind of
work with actors and tables
and chairs for many
years, 20 years or so.
But it wasn't until this, until
something really came together
that was bigger than everybody.
And they all have that
look on their faces
where we've discovered
something that nobody quite owns
but we all do beyond all of us.
And Tiffany came when we
moved to Broadway, finally.
We started in Cambridge
with 100 seats.
And then when we were
moved to Broadway,
he, almost tears in his
eyes, came up to us,
and said we may close early.
And it may not get very far.
But we've come this far,
and it's really great.
And nobody knew that we
would go on like that.
ALAN SEALES: You
won Best Musical.
DAVID PATRICK
KELLY: Say it again?
ALAN SEALES: And then
you won Best Musical.
DAVID PATRICK KELLY:
Yeah, best musical.
But the idea of people
playing their own instruments
and telling a story that since
Elvis, since the Beatles,
on and on, blues folks
forever, the drama
of holding your own instrument
and telling a story there
is really intense.
And we've known it
for a long time.
And it has this global impact.
I see people on the
line afterwards,
when we're talking to folks,
from around the world.
And some don't speak English.
And they're still
moved, because they
know the iconography
of this images
there, all the
different characters.
And so it's really the
thing that is beyond us all.
ALAN SEALES: Oh yes, question.
AUDIENCE: So, I apologize,
I haven't seen the show yet.
Clearly, I have to go see it.
MALE VOICE: Yes, you do.
AUDIENCE: I notice it seems
like it's the kind of show that
would be the kind
of thing you want
to do in a 100-seat theater,
with like an intimate thing.
What was it like
moving something
like that, where you're
breaking the fourth wall so
much, to Broadway
where you've got
this-- all these people and
all this stuff going on.
DAVID PATRICK KELLY:
Well, we were scared.
We had to have workshops
when they had workshops
with the vocal coach
to fill that theater,
to try to bus it up.
And once we're relaxed and
got into it, we understood.
It was OK.
It was a natural thing.
That's amazing that it really
didn't change that much
from 100 seats to
this big theater.
It really did not
adjust that much.
A few lines came and went.
Things like that.
But it just sort of
blossomed all along the way.
And you just had to
adjust a little bit.
PAUL WITTY: At New
York Theatre Workshop,
it was a 200-seat house.
You know, it was very intimate.
And in Cambridge, even less.
I think it was about 100
in that little place.
And so, I mean, all of us were
quite worried about the move
uptown and into an 1,100-seat
theater and what that was going
to do to the delicacy and
the intimacy of the show.
But I think, in fact, it
had the opposite effect
that we felt it
was going to have.
Rather than the show sort of
overwhelm New York Theater
Workshop, it overwhelmed that
200-seat house, because there
was so much sort of
happening on that stage,
even thought it was a
very delicate story.
And I think in the bigger space,
it feels much more delicate.
It feels ooh, look at that
little thing up there.
ALAN SEALES: I think there's
more energy to share.
Because when I watch it, even
in like the sound check earlier,
I was stressed out, herding
all you guys together,
straggling in.
And I sit and then all of a
sudden, you guys start playing.
And I'm captivated by the
energy coming off the stage.
ARTHUR DARVILL: The
nicest thing about the way
the play works as well.
I mean, you guys
haven't seen-- well,
you watched it the other day.
You haven't seen it, but I
watched before I was in it.
And I was amazed by-- you
go to a Broadway show,
and you're like, oh wow!
It's very funny-- it's
very different to London.
I walked in and the ushers were
like (CARNIVAL BARKER TONES)
welcome to the
show of your life!
And you're like oh wow.
OK, great.
We're going to have
a riot in here.
And then you sit down, and this
very, very quiet show starts.
And you're like is
meant to be humming?
And then you're just
completely sold.
It's mesmerizing.
It's an amazing
thing to be part of.
We kind of play
with that on stage,
bring you down as far as
we can without people--
but it's amazing.
You see people just lean in--
you can hear a pin drop--
and listen.
And when it works-- there's
moments when it really works--
it's amazing to be--- yeah.
ALAN SEALES: We've got
time for one question,
then we got to get out
of here unfortunately.
AUDIENCE: This is a question
for Joanna and Arthur.
Just wondering what
I was like coming in
and being replacements
for the original cast.
What it was like, if
you had the opportunity
to reinvent the
characters yourself.
I've seen the show a
couple different times,
so I know it's a little
different with you
guys as the leads,
and great, I may add.
JOANNA CHRISTIE: We
had total freedom.
We barely rehearsed.
ARTHUR DARVILL: We
barely rehearsed.
We just learned it and did it.
JOANNA CHRISTIE: John Tiffany,
our director, was amazing.
We learned and rehearsed
the music back in England,
while we were waiting for
our visas to come through.
And then we got two
days notice that we
were coming, that we
were actually flying.
So they called us
on Friday and said,
we booked your
flights on Sunday.
We were both OK.
And then they're like, and
your first show's on Friday.
We were like what?
ARTHUR DARVILL: We had two
rehearsals, one [INAUDIBLE].
JOANNA CHRISTIE: We had two
rehearsals with these guys,
and then the dress rehearsal,
and then we were on.
John Tiffany's very
clever, I think,
because actually we both
found that liberating,
as opposed to scary.
We found it freeing.
ARTHUR DARVILL: That's also
like John's very, as a director
that we had some-- hey.
As a director, John is amazing.
I don't know if any of you've
seen "Glass Menagerie" yet.
If you haven't, go and see it.
It's the most amazing--
and it's the same team
who put together this.
And I said to John
after, so I said,
how did you get those
guys to act so well?
And he was just, I
just let them get
on with it, which is him
doing himself down completely,
because it's not
as easy as that.
But he has this way of
just empowering actors
to make you feel like
you can do anything
and that you can be confident.
JOANNA CHRISTIE: And also
he didn't try and replace--
I mean, obviously we're both
so different from Cristin
and Steve anyway.
And I think he was clever
in not trying to just
find reincarnations
of them as actors.
He just started
from scratch almost,
and just looked for the
relationship between the two
characters, as opposed to
trying to find another Cristin
and find another Steve
and see if it works,
because it just wouldn't.
And when we were
auditioning-- so
we flew over here for
our last audition.
And we saw the show, which could
have been a horrendous mistake,
as I was watching
Cristin being amazing.
And I was like, oh God, I've
got to try and do this tomorrow.
But John came to me
before my audition
and he said, just do
what you did in London.
And so it gave me
the confidence to go,
OK, I can't try and be Cristin.
I can't do that.
So I just have to have
faith in what I do.
And so, yeah, we were
given a lot of freedom.
And that was liberating.
ARTHUR DARVILL: Yeah, the
material can be [INAUDIBLE].
And the character's called Guy
and Girl, you know what I mean?
I'm really excited about
coming back in 10 years
time and watching
other people do it.
And I think it's those kind of
part-- you'll still be there.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ANDY TAYLOR: I'm the only
one with three children.
ALAN SEALES: Well,
we are at time.
And unfortunately, we
have to wrap this up.
But the show is currently
playing at the Jacobs Theater
here in town.
Go to OnceAMusical.com
to get your tickets.
And everybody go please see it.
It's amazing.
The whole show was incredible.
Thank you guys so much.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]